donc CS Lucas apotre cinema serie presenter
l'armee des morts c'est mental mais une
histoire faire descendre une de ces choses a
King's Landing le show avait la verite
nous voici au bout du monde
au meme moment ayant dans le meme
sens pour  la même raison d'être
qu'ils soient plus durs notre mort est l'ennemi
le premier ennemi et le dernier l'iminium
gagne toujours et nous devons encore le
combattre quitter le patio cynisme
j'ai peur d'accord eh bien il est gadot tu
paries maintenant tu as le centre commercial
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Gayla trolleys clavier un autre pour
chaise tous du même côté Rob Reider
[Musique]
Game of Thrones grésille envoyé
facture d'électricité simultanéité robe
COCs lugu cas suppose au cinéma Siri
Perseus avec lui Sun News
[Musique]
toi